bonjour tout le monde bienvenue dans
notre rendez-vous hebdomadaire l'épisode
4 de la saison 2 de la série loky est
sortie et je n'arrive toujours pas à y
croire c'est quoi cet épisode de fou
furieux nous sommes clairement sur du
niveau de fin de saison alors que nous
sommes qu'à l'épisode 4 bon je préfère
vous prévenir d'emblé on va devoir
parler un peu de voyage dans le temps de
paradoxe on va tenter de démêler tout ça
si possible néanmoins il ne faut pas non
plus qu'on rentre trop dans de grosses
théories interminables car j'en suis
clairement capable restons sur l'épisode
4 nous aurons l'occasion de nous casser
le crâne avec des grosses théories après
l'épisode 6 en attendant n'hésitez pas à
laisser un commentaire avec vos
impressions sur la série ou votre moment
préféré de l'épisode sur ce si vous êtes
prêt commençons car il y a pas mal de
mystères et de petites lignes que nous
devons relever l'épisode s'ouvre de la
même manière que le dernier épisode de
la première saison de Loki nous
annonçons clairement que nous sommes
face à un épisode clé cette fois-ci le
flux temporel sacré est complètement
ramifié il y a des branches de partout
c'est un véritable chaos et le mot a
clairement son importance à la fin des
temps Miss minut dévoile le fameux
secret concernant ravona et on l'avait
deviné c'est le fait qu'elle gouvernait
au côté de celui qui demeure après la
guerre multiverselle guerre où ravona a
tout fait elle a mené celui qui demeure
à la victoire sauf que comme il nous
l'avait été indiqué dans le premier
épisode les membres du TVA ont eu la
mémoire effacée y compris Rav rensleayer
la colère de ravona est donc totalement
compréhensible et pour tout vous avouer
avec cet épisode je pense avoir compris
ce que Marvel souhaite accomplir pour le
personnage ravona souhaite à tout prix
reprendre le TVA et le diriger au point
de nous proposer une des scènes les plus
violente du MCU sans même nous montrer
le résultat mais par la suite cette
dernière va se faire brouiller par
Sylvie qui a manipuler X5 si ravona a
été brouillé cela veut donc dire qu'elle
va atterrir dans le néant le void et
vous savez ce qu'il y a là-bas àos la
créature don Kang s'est servie comme
arme pour gagner la guerre multiverselle
à partir de là je vous avoue pour moi
que cela commence à devenir plus clair
concernant ravona je pense que Marvel
souhaite adapter la saga terminatrix
pour le personnage en fait cette courte
saga de comics qui dure 4atre épisodes
met en vedêre ravonard rensleyer qui va
prendre le contrôle du royaume de Kang
qui est actuellement mort le temps de le
ramener à la vie Ravon dans le MCU avec
sa rébellion suite à la découverte de la
manipulation de celui qui demeure
devient en quelque sorte la terminatrix
des comics ce qui la pousse à devenir
excessivement violente et encore plus
assoifffée par le pouvoir mais du coup
suite à la révélation qu'elle a été une
figure principale de la guerre
multiverselle guerre multiverselle qui a
été victorieuse grâce à l'utilisation
d'alayos plus les troit liens entre ce
dernier et ravona dans les comics et
bien il y a moyen que dans Loki on
découvre que c'était ravona qui a
manipulé àios ou du moins nous allons
possiblement avoir la surprise que
contrairement à tout ce qu'il y a dans
le void alios ne souhaite pas tuer
ravona dans tous les cas terminatrix met
en lumière le fait que ravona a été trop
longtemps dans l'ombre de Kang et que
désormais elle souhaite à tout prix
régner à égal avec lui on retrouve cette
idée en quelque sorte dans le MCU où
ravona souhaite récupérer ce qu'elle
mérite néanmoins je vous avoue que s'il
y a bien un mystère qui me gratte un peu
la tête concernant ce que l'on vient de
parler c'est pourquoi l'enregistrement
de la trahison de celui qui demeure
envers ravona se retrouve dans le passé
du TVA en écoute dans la salle de crise
je vous avoue que je n'ai pas
spécialement de réponse cela peut-être
juste pour que Loki apprenne ce moment
de l'histoire vu que nous sommes dans
une boucle où tout est prédéterminé mais
voilà nous aurons certainement la
réponse plus tard par la suite nous
retrouvons Victor timely dans l'enceinte
du TVA et sincèrement je trouve trouve
que c'est un moment phénoménal que de le
voir découvrir le TVA l'aboutissement de
son autre lui timely est témoin de
l'histoire du flux temporel sacré et la
symbolique est forte je trouve car
seulle face au cycle de destruction et
de renaissance qui détermine l'histoire
du TVA Victor est convoité par
l'ensemble des personnages de la série
en fait je trouve ce moment fort car il
nous montre à quel point le personnage
de kangle conquérant est important dans
le multivers variant ou pas il est la
cause mais il est aussi la solution
c'est lui la clé il est le chaos mais il
est aussi l'ordre bref quand obby et
Victor vont se rencontrer ensuite les
choses sérieuses vont véritablement
commencer comme prévu nous sommes face à
un parfait paradoxe de Bootstrap dont je
vous avais parlé dans la vidéo du
premier épisode obby a écrit le manuel
du TVA en sinspirant des travaux de
Victor timely et Victor de son côté
c'est basé sur le manuel d'obby pour
devenir le génie qu'il est devenu tout
le savoir concernant le TVA n'a donc pas
d'origine c'est une boucle sans fin car
obby a besoin de Victor pour écrire son
bouquin sauf que Victor a besoin d'obby
pour atteindre le savoir et la
connaissance comme le dit oroboros c'est
le serpent qui se mange la queue et vous
connaissez ce symbole c'est une boucle
qui n'a ni début ni fin mais cela va
même encore plus loin l'Ouroboros plus
qu'une simple Bou c'est également le
cycle de la destruction et de la
renaissance du chaos n'est l'ordre et de
l'ordre n'est le chaos une citation qui
s'applique dans la série loky et même
l'univers Marvel dans sa globalité bon
nous le savons tout n'est que boucle et
tout a été prévu par celui qui demeure
en revanche s'il y a un élément qui
m'intrigue concernant le paradoxe de
Bootstrap entre Victor et Ouroboros et
bien c'est que leur boucle implique à la
fois quelqu'un du flux temporel sacré et
un membre du TVA or la question du
placement du TVA a toujours été flou
nous ne savons pas où il se trouve et
Mobius nous a affirmé que le temps se
passait différemment dans le TVA et même
qu'il n'y avait pas de passé du tout
là-bas au final Mobius avait tort Loki
nous a prouvé qu'il existe un passé dans
le TVA et qu'on peut y accéder mais en
plus la mémoire des agents du TVA a été
effacée un nombre incalculable de fois
donc ils ne savent techniquement rien
sur leur agence sauf que le véritable
problème c'est que par définition
mission une boucle temporelle implique
forcément un passé rattaché au futur et
si au roborose qui est un membre du TVA
est impliqué dans une boucle temporelle
avec Victor timely qui est un personnage
du passé du flux temporel sacré est-ce
que cette boucle du coup ne serait pas
un élément avantgardiste nous apportant
une certaine réponse à propos du TVA
est-ce que le TVA ne serait pas
finalement inscrit dans une timeline un
univers mais cela ne s'arrête pas là car
il y a un autre détail qui mérite
clairement d'être souligné c'est que
timely a fini en spaghetti et c'est
peut-être idiot dit comme ça on est dans
de la théorie mais il y a moyen que ce
soit aussi une petite révélation en fait
c'est quelque chose de connu quand on
parle de trou noir il y a cette idée que
l'on pourrait finir en spaghetti
tellement nous serions aplatis et le
truc c'est que oroboros nous en parle
dans l'épisode 1 il met en garde loky
lui annonçant que les trous noirs sont
capables de te transformer en spagette
que Loki soit complètement désassemblé
au point de se désintégrer sauf que
c'est ce qui est arrivé finalement à
Victor timely dans l'épisode 4 et je
suis désolé je vais devoir un peu me
baser sur les derniers éléments du
trailer encore inutilisés et disponibles
à notre connaissance ce concept de
spaghettification si je puis dire va
continuer plusieurs éléments vont se
désintégrer ou du moins se désassembler
dans les deux prochains épisodes donc
est-ce que par rapport à tout ce que
nous avons dit auparavant et et ce
nouveau concept le TVA n'aurait pas un
lien étroit avec les trous noirs est-ce
qu'il ne serait pas par hasard placé
dans l'un d'entre eux par exemple en
fait on parle de ce concept de spaghetti
mais ce n'est pas ça le plus intéressant
vous le savez dans le TVA il n'y a pas
de magie il n'y a pas d'enchantement ou
quoi que ce soit tout est scientifique
et pour cause qu'Angle conquérant est un
scientifique tout ce qui compose le
personnage c'est la science la
technologie et le savoir rien de plus si
l'on se tourne vers le concept de trou
noir déjà il y a cette idée que la
gravité est tellement intense que le
temps est énormément ralenti je dis ça
juste pour l'exemple ce n'est pas
forcément vrai mais une semaine passée
dans un Tron noir pourrait équivaloir à
100 années sur Terre par exemple et ça
c'est une idée qui correspond
parfaitement au TVA car nous savons
qu'il y a une temporalité là-bas
puisqu'il y a un passé et un futur
néanmoins le temps semble complètement
différent de ce que nous avons eu
l'occasion de voir dans d'autres œuvres
ensuite l'autre point fondamental et le
plus important c'est que les trous noirs
plient tellement l'espace et le temps
qu'ils créent des boucles temporelles
naturelles prenez une paille par exemple
une feuille ou peu importe quelque chose
que vous pouvez plier faites rejoindre
les de bouts et vous venez de former une
boucle le début de votre paille ou votre
feuille et la fin ont fusionner pour
former la boucle est-ce que vous voyez
le concept le passé forme donc le futur
et le futur forme donc le passé mais le
plus impressionnant encore c'est que
cette boucle en fait est propre au trou
noir et non ce qui est en dehors par
exemple le trou noir vient d'apparaître
et tu y places le TVA là-bas à partir de
ce moment-là l'histoire du TVA va donc
devenir une boucle où le passé et le
futur vont se rejoindre peut-être que je
m'emballe peut-être que j'ai tort
peut-être que je cherche des réponses là
où il n'y a pas besoin d'en trouver mais
je pense sincèrement que tout ceci a son
importance surtout quand on sait que que
Kang et donc celui qui demeure n'est
qu'un scientifique cela veut donc dire
que le TVA le voyage dans le temps ou
tout autre élément doit pouvoir se
répondre et quand on regarde la fin de
l'épisode 4 c'est comme si le TVA
devenait néant on est complètement dans
le noir comme dans un trou noir du coup
et par conséquent à la fin de l'épisode
4 nous sommes face à l'émergence du
véritable chaos du cycle l'histoire que
nous suivons dans l'oki est une boucle
on nous amène des concepts comme
l'uroboros le cycle de destruction et de
renaissance celui qui demeure vous avez
tisé sur le concept de l'ordre et du
chaos et comme le dit Loki tout brûlé
tout anilé pour tout recommencer c'est
facile et ce qu'il nous dit là est bien
plus significatif qu'il le croit car
c'est un concept complètement exploité
par kangle conquérant dans son histoire
la preuve dans cantouania c'est plus
facile de détruire le TVA et de le
rebattir derrière du chaos naîra donc
l'ordre néanmoins comme le dit Loki
c'est plus difficile de réparer et il
est là le point important nous nous
n'avons toujours pas eu de véritabl
réponses concernant l'érance temporelle
du personnage et nous le savons de par
le trailer la question ne semble pas
encore réglé et pour cause il semble que
ce soit peut-être même la solution nous
ne savons pas pourquoi Loki est le seul
et unique personnage à être baladé dans
le présent le passé et le futur au point
de créer une boucle temporelle avec
lui-même celui qui demeure avait choisi
Loki et Sylvie comme ses remplaçants il
les a guidé tout au long de la saison 1
pour prendre sa place personnellement je
meand demande si lors de la destruction
du TVA Loki ne va pas de nouveau avoir
une errance toporelle qui va le sortir
de cette situation pour recommencer
l'histoire nous voyons d'ailleurs des
plans de l'épisode 1 de la saison 1
c'est fritant dans le trailer et un
autre où Loki se rencontre lui-même à
plusieurs reprises on ne sait pas vers
quoi on se dirige exactement pour la fin
de la saison 2 l'épisode 4 aurait
clairement pu être un final de saison et
je suis très curieux du coup de voir ce
qu'ils vont nous proposer il ne faut pas
oublier que bien que la série loky soit
un prétexte pour parler de multivers
Kang ou encore le TVA elle s'appelle
quand même bien Loki le personnage
principal est donc et restera Loki donc
il y a de grandes chances que notre
héros nous amène son fameux glorieux
destin en attendant je vous propose que
l'on s'arrête là l'épisode était
incroyable j'ai tenté d'apporter
certaines réponses mais le but de Marvel
là était de nous surprendre et nous
apporter un énorme cliffunger je vous ai
proposé mon point de vue et mon avis
nous sommes même sortis un peu de
l'épisode mais tout est possible pour la
fin je vous avoue que personnellement
moi j'ai une attente c'est que on nous
bacine depuis longtemps avec la guerre
multiverselle et les nombreux variants
de Kang la fin de la saison 2 pour moi
qui baigne d'ailleurs complètement dans
le chaos après l'ordre qui nous était
représenté dans la saison 1 doit nous
montrer du coup un véritable avantgoût
du conflit on doit voir des variants de
Kang on doit voir la menace de the Kang
dynasye et Secret Wars avant pourquoi
pas une potentielle saison 3 de Loki
bref j'ai très hâte de l'épise épisode 5
dites-moi ce que vous en avez pensé en
commentaire n'oubliez pas le petit pouce
bleu et à vous abonner c'était targoroc
que le lion heart soit avec vous allez
ciao tout le
[Musique]
monde